[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRESENTER 1: My
SuperUROP project
is about making a
program run faster.
PRESENTER 2: Developing the
iOS version of App Inventor
in order to democratize
cross-platform mobile
development.
PRESENTER 3: Routing of drones
in communications-constrained
environments.
PRESENTER 4: Introduce
economic and political factors
into a machine learning model.
PRESENTER 5: Helping
teachers give better feedback
on student's code.
PRESENTER 6: This project
was a new field for me.
It involved computer
vision and robotics.
PRESENTER 7: We did
a clinical trial
with 3 donors and 11 patients.
PRESENTER 8: I got
the opportunity
to try out one of
these algorithms
at the Boston Symphony
Orchestra a couple of weeks
ago, with very
promising results.
PRESENTER 9: Being
part of this program
has forced me to better
summarize and communicate
ideas.
PRESENTER 10: Working
one-on-one with my supervisor
was extremely useful.
PRESENTER 2: I want to
mobile development as a job,
and so it gave me a very
big full-year project
to work on that.
PRESENTER 1: It gives you some
guidance and an opportunity
to really know
how to communicate
your work in a professional
and academic setting.
PRESENTER 2: It
gave me the skills
when it came to writing
an actual proposal,
writing a research paper.
PRESENTER 5: It allowed
me to implement a product
and add features to
something that existed,
which is something that
I really love to do.
PRESENTER 9: It forces
you to take a problem
and kind of break it down into
its fundamental root causes.
That's a great skill to have.
[MUSIC PLAYING]